so i'm clearly nailing it at all these things
when am i ever going to use this as a lawyer jen
when you have powers like this it's like putting a
target on your back in the backs of all the people
you care about oh cool yet another way my life
is grown thanks bruce all right all i've been
doing is showing you the downsides of being a hulk
but there are a few upsides my body's metabolize
alcohol at an incredibly fast rate which means
that we can drink so much and not get drunk
All buzz no barf. Feels good
Welcome back everyone this will be my new she-hulk
trailer video daredevil and world war hulk i know
a lot of people have been asking if they're ever
gonna do world war hulk story in the marvel movies
or marvel disney plus series don't worry i'll
explain what's going on because it does seem
like this is the beginning of them setting up
a really big arc for the hulk family just in
general just because they're doing so many more
hulk characters in the mcu if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them all
also do a marvel giveaway when that's going on
too but just starting with the brand new trailer
footage first hulk is showing she-hulk how to use
some of her powers we only see part of the montage
in the new trailer but it goes on a little bit
longer like he goes through all the steps of all
their abilities all their weaknesses everything
about being a hulk having those gamma powers we
got a little bit of a teaser in the last trailer
about how she gets her she-hulk powers in the
comics she actually got a transfusion from bruce
banner and that's how she got his gamma-infused
blood it basically took over her normal red
blood cells and gave her the powers of a hulk
that's kind of what happens during the events of
this series but they're using this car crash to
sort of explain how that happens it sounds like it
happens during the actual car crash but they don't
explain exactly how his blood gets inside her body
it just sounds like they have like a really nasty
car wreck you also see his arm in the sling too
so they will explain how his arm healed because in
all this other footage his arm looks totally fine
he teaches her about their healing factor pushing
her off the cliff just to show her that nothing
bad will happen to her like you'll eat this like
it's no big deal they also kind of use this to
show you the tone of the series when she literally
flips him off as she's flying off the cliff then
they just make the joke about them not being able
to get drunk anymore and i think they made the
same joke during captain america the first avenger
when he got his super soldier powers they did say
that there are going to be a lot of comic book
references in the series with all the cameo scenes
obviously references to other characters like
daredevil abomination wong that's really just the
beginning they said they also have references to
the 1970s incredible hulk series like during this
scene here where they make the ad for her law firm
mr mcgee don't make me angry you wouldn't
like me when i'm angry don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry like the joke
there is that they're making an ad for her law
firm but they're making it in the style of the
1970s tv ad he's also dressed exactly like the
david banner character whose name they changed
because originally he was supposed to be bruce
banner like that's who the character is even
though they changed his name for the tv series
even going so far as to use some of his
dialogue he wouldn't like me when i'm angry
speaking of which there was even a joke that we
spotted to the hawkeye series in the tracksuit
bros because when she's scrolling her phone like
she becomes super popular on social media and all
those dating apps all the people on the dating
scene in the mcu really loves them some she-hulk
really love the idea that death by snooze knew
when you're scrolling past some of the names
in her chat you actually see tracksuit bros here
so some of the tracksuit bros are like huge fans
of she-hulk now they even had a tracksuit bros
easter egg during the miss marvel episodes at
the end because that takes place in jersey city
which is very close to new york city obviously and
it'll be around the area where kingpin controls
where he's very active don't worry i'll talk about
kingpin all the daredevil stuff in a second the
other big teaser that he drops during this clip is
when he's talking to jen about all the downsides
of being a hulk in their game of powers putting a
target on their back that's mostly a reference to
people like thunderbolt ross coming for them this
is all meant to be lead up for the thunderbolts
movie in what's happening around captain america 4
in the dark avengers even though it's kind of more
of a thunderbolts thing like it's dark avengers
but it's kind of thunderbolts same basic concept
them putting together a really dark version of
the avengers like a dark team that the government
that the military are able to control all through
val's character the actor william hurt did pass
away it was very sad so obviously they're gonna
have to swerve a little bit on what they do with
thunderbolt ross in the movies they might use his
name to inspire the creation of the thunderbolts
because they were kind of setting up the concept
that he was pulling the strings for val like she
had a contact inside the us military that was
sanctioning everything that she was doing even
though it was super shady putting together this
team of anti-heroes like she told us agent like
what's something that's kind of gray area that we
can't call the avengers for that's where you roll
in the thunderbolts in the dark avengers although
like i said it seems like they're doing more
thunderbolt stuff just because that is the end
of marvel phase 5. one of the big tropes of that
is red hulk we're doing so much more hulk stuff
in the mcu and during the incredible hulk movie
there are a lot of deleted scenes that they wound
up cutting out of the film where he talks about
wanting the power of banner for himself which is
all just teasing red hulk stuff if you remember
the incredible hulk was actually supposed to be
a trilogy of movies they did have plans to bring
the leader back and make him a bigger bill a lot
of people asking if the leader is going to show
up during the she-hulk series it's always possible
but i haven't heard any rumors about that but
here's where we get to the world war hulk of it
all so they're introducing she-hulk they want to
introduce more hulk family members like there are
many different hulk based characters if marvel's
been having problems doing a solo hulk film and
finding the right story for that a really easy
way to pull that off would be to do a world war
hulk story where something happens to the banner
version of hulk that drives him crazy and he turns
into the world breaker hulk now that's a little
bit of a different concept in the comics world
war hulk was a slightly different event which
they already kind of did the plot of during
thor ragnarok during that story he swears revenge
on the illuminati which they actually just did
during dr strange ii multiverse of madness in the
838 universe he swears revenge on them and so the
heroes of earth basically band together to stop
hulk who's gone completely off the rails and wants
to kill all of them at least the first part of
the series is basically him just tearing through
all the most powerful marvel heroes you thought
the scarlet witch really gave it to black bolt
during doctor strange too during world war
hulk hulk really gives it to black bolt
but imagine a version of captain america civil
war for example that turns around the idea world
war hulk with banner going out of control the
avengers trying to stop him and then when the
avengers don't do what the government wants
them to do what the military wants them to do
val brings in a team of thunderbolts quote-unquote
to take out the hulk they didn't say who the
villain of the thunderbolts movie is going to
be a lot of people actually think that it's
going to be the leader because they might just
go with a more despicable villain but i do think
that actually be pretty cool for them to do a
world war hulk story through captain america 4
in the thunderbolts movie they might wind up
doing multiple seasons of the she-hulk series
we'll see about that i think it just depends
on how many seasons of she-hulk they want to do
it sounds like right now the banner version of
hulk is going to be part of at least the first
part of the she-hulk series he might show up at
the end too but i think during the course of the
series we will see something happen to him in
the background that will tease the future of
his story in the mcu a lot of you also asking if
jenn walters is also going to be part of avengers
5 kang dynasty they literally make avengers jokes
like about her joining the team during the actual
trailer so i think it's a pretty safe bet that she
will be in avengers 5 in some way part of the idea
of the series 2 is her getting the powers in the
refusal of the call to action like hulk is telling
her though you have these powers you have a
responsibility but she's like i don't want any of
that i just want to be a normal green eight-foot
tall giant lawyer so obviously during the course
of the series she's just gonna slowly make peace
with the idea that she has these powers she has
a responsibility to be a superhero on the side
but one of the connections to daredevil is that
just like daredevil matt murdock she continues to
be a lawyer while also being a superhero so even
though she's going to be involved in all these big
crossover movies avengers 5 avengers 6 secret wars
she'll still continue to operate representing
superheroes and super villains in court
like we've been talking about the daredevil born
again series which is going to be dropping pretty
soon actually let's start filming it pretty soon
it'll be 18 episodes total they'll be bringing
back a bunch of the marvel netflix characters
for that like jessica jones we'll probably see
luke cage show up at some point the punisher will
also probably come back at some point during that
and even though he'll be involved in avengers 5
and avengers 6 like these really big really crazy
things it's mostly meant to be a ground level
series he'll continue to operate as lawyer matt
murdock during the day that's also why i'm
hoping for him to have a cameo scene or some
kind of bigger crossover during spider-man
4 just because they're taking spider-man
back to like friendly neighborhood spider-man
in the mcu even though he is also going to be
involved in avengers 5 and avengers 6 but don't be
surprised if we see more thunderbolts more world
war hulk more hulk related stuff going on inside
the she-hulk series they've been rumors about them
doing scar son of hulk i don't know if that's
actually true but we might also see hulk ling
show up during the secret invasion series
he doesn't actually have gamma based powers
all of his powers the fact that he looks green
comes from him being a scroll so then calling him
hulk ling is more of an affectation and because
we did just find out about the daredevil born
again series i will do more videos about that as
we get more easter eggs and teasers we're going
to see daredevil obviously show up during the
she-hulk episodes i think he's going to be in a
couple episodes then he's going to be in the echo
series with kingpin next year and then he'll be
in the daredevil born again series that'll take
place after the echo series will you wait for
everything everyone click here for my brand new
guardians of the galaxy 3 trailer video with the
first look at adam warlock and click here for my
brand new she-hulk trailer and ghost rider easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!